all right we now have a special
prosecutor in the Trump Russia
investigation after Donald Trump fired
FBI director James Comey last week we
had the revelation earlier this week
that Donald Trump allegedly asked James
Comey to drop the FBI's investigation
into disgraced former national security
adviser Michael Flynn
we heard calls from both sides mostly
from Democrats but from some Republicans
as well for an independent counsel also
known as a special prosecutor to be
assigned to oversee this entire Trump
Russia investigation and one of the
reasons for this is that and and this is
a fear that escalated with the would be
the firing of James Comey was the fear
that Donald Trump would appoint a new
FBI director that would just favor the
President and compromise the integrity
of yet another investigation not that we
haven't seen other investigations into
Trump Russia already compromised a very
reasonable concern some Republicans have
still been resisting the idea of
bringing in an outsider but the Justice
Department has a secound to the pressure
you could say and it was announced that
Deputy Attorney General rod Rosenstein
he's the guy who's been acting as
Attorney General in all Russia related
matters after Jeff Sessions recused
himself with the exception of Jeff
Sessions recommending the firing of
James Comey in any case rod Rosenstein
has appointed former FBI director robert
muller as special prosecutor to
facilitate this investigation into the
Trump Russia scandal if that name sounds
familiar it's because again he was the
FBI director appointed by George W Bush
in oh one served until 2013 when James
Comey took over so the obvious question
is are we going to get an unbiased and
fair investigation as a result of this
on the one hand yeah Muller's a
Republican he still technically answers
to Rosenstein and Trump but he's not
known as a partisan hack he has no
direct ties to Donald Trump that we know
of as of right now no major
controversies in his past he stood up
when george w bush was abusing his power
Obama liked him enough to extend his
term when he was FBI director and I
think most people know that
you'll be more impartial than whoever
Trump would have appointed to replace
James Comey yeah and that is good news
it just comes as a surprise though
because Rosenstein was as you mentioned
very influential in the firing of James
Comey yeah so it seemed as this he was
trying to sweep this whole Russia
investigation under the rug so this is a
complete 180 very good news especially
because the FBI investigation and the
house investigation have both been
significantly undermined in the
documents discredited to some degree a
quote from Deputy Attorney General rod
Rosenstein what I have determined is
that based upon the unique circumstances
the Public Interest requires me to place
this investigation under the authority
of a person who exercises a degree of
independence from the normal chain of
command a special counsel was necessary
in order for the American people to have
full confidence in the outcome according
to White House officials Donald Trump
didn't find out about the appointment of
a special prosecutor until after the
appointment was made and he reportedly
wasn't happy about it at all which is
terrific and Trump responded to all of
this in a statement yesterday saying
quote as I have stated many times a
thorough investigation will confirm what
we already know there was no collusion
between my campaign and any foreign
entity I look forward to this matter
concluding quickly yeah I bet Trump
wants this to conclude quickly that
that's obviously clear the Department of
Justice sort of had no choice so I know
you're reading in due to rod Rosenstein
decision as a sort of 180 did they
really have a choice I mean as you as
you pointed out the FBI investigation
had been tarnished by the firing of
James Comey the house investigation has
been a joke for months at this point the
entire executive branch would look so
corrupt if they didn't do this and they
probably know that but yet it is still
curious that one of the guys who
recommended firing Comey now says let's
put in a special prosecutor and they're
also looking out for themselves too
right they have to keep their own hands
clean and yeah it is it is remarkable
that Trump is trying to speed up this
investigation because as it goes on
there's more of a chance of them finding
something that's why he asked Comey to
end the investigation into Michael Flynn
saying he's a good guy though yeah Greg
no good no good guy has ever committed a
crime worthy of investigation Democratic
Senator Ben Cardin of Maryland said
yesterday quote rather than make this go
away Deputy Attorney General Rosenstein
has taken an important step toward
restoring the credibility of the DOJ and
FBI in this most serious matter
so like James Comey Robert Muller will
not have to consult with or inform the
Justice Department nor the White House
about the investigation the FBI has
already said we are not going to be
keeping the White House up-to-date on
what is going on with this investigation
Trump will undoubtedly replace Comey
eventually with someone who is friendly
to trump and we definitely don't want
that person leading the investigation so
now at least we have the appearance that
the DOJ investigation is getting more
serious we'll see if it actually does it
would have been better if an independent
prosecutor could have been appointed by
Congress because then Trump wouldn't
even be able to fire that person but
Trump would not be able to fire Robert
Mulder without significant scrutiny I
mean I think that these things take time
Watergate took about a year and a half
before Richard Nixon eventually resigned
so I think there's an urgency to try to
get Trump out of office now but it could
take years
it could and it also might not be that
great for Democrats and I'm going to out
next week we're going to dig into that
but people online already talking about
oh this is the beginning of the end I
think it's a little soon to say that for
now